a very famous guest in America and all
over the world uh Mr Robert Spencer uh
Robert Spencer is the editor of the
Jihad watch website uh he's a shelman
fellow at the David harwitz fre uh
Center uh
David uh Roberts
actually wrote 28 books many of them are
New York Times Best Sellers so
very famous guy also
Robert
trained some FBI staff US Command Staff
US Army staff on Islam and
Jihad so it's a great honor to welcome
Robert today greatt to be here thank
you so Robert as you know we discussed
previously uh I share some of some of my
views but before I want to go into the
did you ever have a Muslim guy talking
to you from a Muslim country before or
this is the first time no there was
another one
um I'm trying to remember maybe
Egypt yeah I think so I'm thinking of
one that was a guy from Nigeria but he
was not a Muslim if I recall correctly
and of course Nigeria is not entirely a
Muslim country at least not
yet but uh no you're abely absolutely
right this is unusual and I is unusual I
hope that this is going to go viral to
show people that uh even Muslim guys
Muslim people would agree I may disagree
with Robert in some small things but I I
would agree with him with the with
most so as I told you Roberts I started
questioning some of the things uh at a
young age and on the theology side of it
I I agree with you in in many things I
can see that many conflicts especially
in the Middle
East uh Islam is being used as a as a
scapegoat and it's also being used
uh in many countries uh in politics and
to to change people's view of of life
and of politics in general uh I'm lucky
that I was raised in Morocco under the
leadership of uh of Kings who were a bit
uh more openminded and we had the we had
we had the many Jews who lived in
Morocco for a while and
uh we we still have issues in Morocco
but it's a different country we have a
different view of things I was not
raised as as an extremist I was only I
was and they told you because uh before
we had this interview you told me oh you
may get in trouble in Morocco I was
actually I started uh openly supporting
the the existence of Israel writing
things about Israel a while back and uh
we still
have uh we have a we have freedom of
speech and and freedom of of thinking
here uh so Robert what I want to focus
with you on today as I told you we want
to focus a bit on what's going on in
Israel and the Palestinian Israeli
conflict and how you think it's it's
it's not it's not uh it's not going to
be solved anytime soon with politics
because most of
it is lot of people especially on the
other side who would view it as a
religious War absolutely yeah you know
you read what Hamas puts out in their
statements their explanations of what
they're doing their calls for support
read Palestinian Islamic Jihad even
material for from the Palestinian
Authority
itself Islam is always the center of the
conflict it's always framed in Islamic
terms and yet you turn around and read
the United Nations the European Union
and the US state department about the
conflict and there's one thing that's
conspicuously never mentioned at all
ever in any way shape or form as having
anything to do with the conflict and
that's Islam and I S suggest that this
is one reason why all the negotiated
settlements that have come out of the
state department and the global human
rights apparatus have failed and why
they're all doomed to fail because they
don't address the problem at its roots
they don't deal with the real reason for
the conflict they ignore the real reason
for the conflict and so they can never
hope to fix
it yeah you're right so we can see that
uh at some point after the you've been
talking about this in some of your books
and some of your
your interviews after the after the the
breakdown of the Ottoman Empire they
were said there was uh originally in the
Middle East there were some pan pan
arabism that we can call it pan arabism
which was kind of secular that did not
actually work and we can see that
islamization of societies came in
politization politization of
Islam uh can we talk about about the the
role of Saudi Arabia at that time Saudi
Arab very big role in the destruction of
Arab nationalism Arab nationalism is as
you noted a postor war I movement that
came out of the ashes of the Ottoman
Empire and it arose in the first place
from the Arabs who had always challenged
ottoman rule even before the empire fell
going back to to the wahhabi starting in
the in the 18th century but after the
fall of the Empire when Adat Turk and
turkey was saying the reason why the
empire fell was because of Islam the
immoral Theology of uh no the dead
Theology of an immoral bedin he said and
uh the the he rejected political Islam
as the basis for the government of
turkey created secularism in Turkey
which of course is now on its way out
and in the Arab world there was a
similar movement that the Arab states
would come together and the Arab peoples
in general would come together on the
basis of their shared Arabia their
shared Arabic identity and it would not
be based on Islam if the Christian Arabs
would be included as a matter of fact of
course this movement in to a tremendous
degree was spearheaded by the Christian
Arabs and so it was
uh the basis for for the movements that
put Saddam Hussein and the assads in
power and uh it's at a time of the end
of the 20th century it seemed as if Arab
nationalism was the wave of the future
and that secularism would continue to
spread in the Arab world and in the
Islamic World in general but the Saudis
were
meanwhile making a contrary motion and
spreading wahhabi Islam all around the
world
trying especially to work against the
areas where the Arabs had secularized
and also against bring them back to the
religion saying you know you're angering
Allah you're moving you're you're acting
against the commands of Allah you are
bringing destruction upon your countries
unless you return to the path of Allah
and this ultimately prevailed so that
now we see Arab nationalism is more of a
matter of History than of present day
reality and Islam is resurgent in the
Islamic world this is largely the
handiwork of the
Saudis yeah it is a they did Heavy work
and the Muslim populations all over the
world they still can't
grasp the the danger of the sis right
now I've been WR reading some articles
other than what was using there is there
is a new word that we call Sport washing
it's using for example sponsorship of
sports and sports team
that qar was using also qar the
terrorist country terrorist organization
that I call how the hell can a country
host a bunch of terrorists such as
Hamas uh then they they buy teams in
Europe they buy they sponsor uh so this
is a new word and and Saudi is doing the
same thing you heard about the gulf
league and they also invited the Trump
to it and the different golf champions
so Saudi Arabia is doing a big game
right now tricking people into uh
believing that they changed a couple of
weeks ago thousands of pilgrims died in
Saudi Arabia how can a single country
control one of the pillars of
Islam I I was thinking about this for
the last couple of months trying to
write an article about it
analyzing how
this country cannot they they actually
Tak in millions of dollars even probably
billions of dollars from this pilgrimage
every year other than the income that
they have from oil and other things but
they still cannot help other countries
maybe even their own people if you go
from outside of Mecca and the Medina
you'll see poverty in Saudi Arabia
you'll see uh people who are
homeless uh that's what I heard I've
never been in Saudi Arabia but I'm
trying to attack Saudi Arabia maybe I'll
I'll end up like kazaki at some point
you never
know but the thing about Saudi Arabia
the sports watching they're imitating
the Communist Chinese because look how
the Communist Chinese bought the
National Basketball Association and so
now you have the NBA working in China
spreading basketball in China that's
fine no problem there but then when the
big stars of the NBA in the United
States are asked what do do you think
about China they refuse to criticize it
and so China has this tremendous
legitimacy that it bought by buying the
NBA it's the same thing now that the
Saudis are trying to do with the PGA and
the golfers that they buy a legitimacy
in the west the problem right now is
that the American media is not talking
about this a lot of people are not
discussing this and this is a danger
same thing I'm going to come back to the
islamization of America and its campuses
with the financing of Q I'll come back
to that Qatar is doing many other crazy
things in America other than what Saudi
is do the Saudis are doing and these
things need to be discussed with the
American people with the Western World
this is something that's been
done uh postco people are still
struggling with their with the rise of
prices people are confused elections are
coming in the in
America uh
but media need to talk about this so uh
I want to go back again to uh to Saudi
Arabia and Iran what do you think about
the Iran role and its use of
Islam uh to spread its violence using
its prce you know we have at least four
four proes that I know of Hamas heah and
the htis in in Yemen and we also I
believe we have a proxy of of Iran here
in Morocco which is the poisar front uh
who are been uh uh giv us a hard time
here uh in our southern region of
Morocco which is the Moroccan Sahara but
there
been even Iran is trying to to to take
over I don't know what they're trying to
do even in Africa and attacking Muslim
country such as
Morocco I wouldn't be at all surprised
if that were the case uh a few years
back the uh Iranian regime was
discovered to be
financing a Marxist uh party in
Spain and they were just trying to
destabilize the society which they hope
will work to their interests in the long
term but actually it's the same thing we
were talking about Saudi Arabia and its
role in defeating Arab nationalism the
Iranians also played a large role in
this even though they're Shiite with the
Iranian Revolution they showed the
islamists that they had the ability to
take over a state even a highly
functioning respected State as the
Iranian regime was under the Sha and
islamize it and ruled by Sharia and so
they gave a tremendous impetus to the
Islamic movement both in the Sunni world
as well as the
Shia well do you think is there another
Danger from the Shia where it's I know
that you think all of all the sects are
the same but you think is there is there
is there danger coming from Iran well
the the the Iranians want to rule the
Islamic world but they have a big
disadvantage because they're Shiite and
so they're only 15% of the Islamic world
and the sunnis don't want to be ruled by
Shia but the Iranians are working about
working this out very systematically
they uh have Iraq and George W bush gave
them Iraq because he toppled Saddam
Hussein and then he put in elections and
the elections it was inevitable the
Shiites would vote for Shia and the
sunnis would vote for Sunni and so the
Irani the Iraqis because it's 55% Shiite
instituted a Shiite government in
Baghdad and then that became a satellite
of Iran so they got Iraq in uh Lebanon
of course they've been moving in people
and they have hisbah and so they had
this historically Christian area that is
now probably majority Shiite because
they have been systematically targeting
it and bringing people in in Syria the
alawites rule and the alawites are
beholden to the Shiites because the
Shiite mullah gave them a certification
that they were genuinely Islamic
otherwise they probably would have been
toppled already and so they've got this
whole
area and it wouldn't take much really
the big the obviously the big obstacles
are Saudi Arabia in Egypt and turkey to
a lesser degree because it's a little
bit uh out out of this particular region
but nonetheless this is a tremendous
group of a a tremendous expans of
territory that the Iranians already have
a tremendous degree of control over and
so it's not so fanciful anymore that
they could become the rulers of the
Islamic world yeah but at the end of the
day we come back to the people like the
Muslim people how I mean many people
from that region are
undereducated
underemployed maybe if they're employed
they're underemployed there is poverty
there is so they're they're easy to to
control let's go back a bit to the to
the Israeli palestin conflict in these
two countries how do you see them
getting involved I did an interview I
was actually I was in
Israel uh I did an interview with il TV
which is part of the wet group where I
spoke about uh at that point
there was a a potential normalization
between Israel and Saudi
Arabia and I actually in my interview I
discussed the potential normalization
and how I wanted I actually suggested to
to Israel and the Israeli politicians to
be careful about uh what the sis would
would want because zis again they see
themselves as the protector of Islam and
Islamic sites and that would be
dangerous step for for Israeli
politicians to to get to give them
whatever they want especially
controlling some part of the Temple
Mount and the Islamic sites and things
like that so how do you see both let's
start with Saudi Arabia and Iran getting
involved in these uh in this conflict
well the Saudis are in a difficult
position when it comes to the conflict
because they're threatened by Iran and
so the first the TR Trump Administration
and then the Biden Administration also
has been trying to get them to come to
an accord with Israel like the Abraham
Accords if not join the Abraham Accords
forly at least come to some Accord with
Israel because the Abraham Accords are
built on the idea that the sunny states
have a shared threat with Israel that a
shared threat from Iran that they that
they can get together with Israel to try
to counter because Israel's threatened
by Iran bahin and the of them are also
threatened by Iran so they can get
together on that basis the Saudis also
are threatened by Iran and so that was
the idea behind the Accord the problem
is that now especially since the war has
broken out ever since the Hamas attack
on Israel on October 7th the Saudis
can't come to an accord with Israel
because it would look as if they're
betraying the entire Islamic Nation the
entire umah is being betrayed if they're
the the custodians of the two holy
places this would play very badly so
there's not going to be any Accord right
now and any talk of it now it's just
fantasy what about uh Iran do you think
uh you know I had this uh I was doing
this
analysis uh just thinking about this I
was like wouldn't
Iran want to get rid of its proxies
Hamas and Hezbollah because the they
want to probably move on at some point
why as an Iran State you mean just
attack Israel directly no like maybe
they they're not gonna be supporting
them anymore they just want to get rid
of all these things maybe uh you never
know who's who's maybe if Trump is
coming next I don't think this is going
to work for them but if a Democrat a
crazy Democrat again such
as Maybe Obama or something like that
maybe they'll make a deal again or you
never know I was just thinking about
this what do you think well there's
there's no way I don't think that Iran
is going to get rid of its proxies it's
not going to moderate even if Trump does
become president again because remember
how they were very antagonistic toward
Trump while he was president before and
the idea that
uh they would be pacified I think is out
of the question however it is possible
that they will be less belligerent
although probably very hostile in terms
of rhetoric but less belligerent because
they know that Trump is not to be
trifled with the way that Biden is and
so they might become more restrained in
their actions and not cut loose the
proxies but fund them less also of
course they always have to balance the
funding with their the the shakiness of
their own regime and how it's very it's
very telling how the demonstrators Iran
last year were shouting many times we
saw this on many videos them shouting we
don't care about Palestine that they
should stop in other words funding Hamas
and his fah and use the money for the
people of Iran yeah and so this is
something that may come back again to
haunt them yeah and this is what I I
just said it's it's gonna at some point
is Gonna Come the word yes and the
actions will come to the people people
will at some point I may I may not we
may not even be here but you never know
what's going to happen next I see people
maybe people will be more educated maybe
more critical thinkers and things like
that but at some point I don't I don't
see this is going anywhere without uh uh
the people making their own decisions
because people are sick of uh leaders
who are making Iran you have 90 90
million people there
uh and I don't think most of them are
are agreeing with whatever their
government is doing you know it's
astonishing did you see the poll the
survey from last year that only 40% of
Iranians identified as Muslim anymore
and officially of course Iran is 99%
Muslim but all those people are just so
disenchanted after and you know why
Islam you know why and I'll explain this
because we may have this even in even in
North Africa now because you see all all
these bad Deeds that their Muslim
leaders are doing bad Deeds that
politicians are doing so they they'll be
like they're not going to change their
religion they they'll probably become
atheists or theists as I became at some
point so uh so you never know I mean
when you're a critical thinker uh you'll
be like what the hell is going
on what is this religion where you have
a lot of corruption you have a lot of
people killing each other especially in
the in that side of the of the of the of
the of the world so of course you're
going to be thinking twice about staying
as a
Muslim so let's let's go back to uh
let's let's move a bit to the Western
World now and the spread of islamism so
as I told you here in Morocco we're
close to uh to Europe and I've seen and
I heard in the news and things how
islamism and the spread of uh islamism
in especially in France and UK you've
been banned from the UK for your for
your for your uh for your ideologies
you're you're free I mean you're not a
violent person you just spread an
ideology and a way of thinking that is
that I I trust is something logical they
said
you they they said that I was banned for
saying Islam is not a religion of Peace
yeah I heard
you said Islam is Islam is obedience
right that's what you said submission
submission yeah something like that yeah
I heard that so uh and you can see UK
the UK is considered one of the
democratic countries of the world and uh
and they've been trapped in getting all
those uh not controlling I mean I'm not
talking about getting immigrants in
that's a different issue the control of
immigration and Muslim immigration I'm
not talking about that what I'm talking
about is the control of the spread of
islamism and the hateful speech extreme
and violent acts and things like that
I've seen I was in the UK I actually
studied there back in 2011 that I've
seen the
hateful
uh I mean I was called a paky like the
some white guys called me a paky because
they thought I was a Pakistani or
something so there is so there is there
is some uh you can see that there's a
kind of a pressure social pressure
between uh between uh different
different people and uh the UK has been
having issues with this with the with
the spread of you've been having a I
can't remember his name this Egyptian
cleric who was uh he had his I taken off
during The Afghani War who was giv
speeches inside London
Abu Hamza
yeah I don't know what the UK or their
intelligence Services were trying to
play with all bringing all those people
in but uh that actually brought a lot of
a lot of issues France with all the
attacks that they actually in Morocco
with the coordination with the some
Moroccan Services they actually were
helping and actually they're helping
France right now with their upcoming uh
Olympic Games Morocco has a long
experience with the with
terrorist
uh with Terror and
terrorists
uh
so I wrote an article I think last month
with the think tank Middle East Forum
where I did the small research
piece about uh a mosque in
Michigan who alized
mder was uh
killed executed by the Israelis inside
Lebanon so I was actually the first uh
the first I think I wrote I read that
news in your in your newsletter they did
some more research about it talked to
some to some experts back in Tel Aviv
here in the US no response from that
musk
uh those kind of things actually scare
even though I'm not I don't live in the
US but those kind of things
may go to something
else how the hell can you believe that a
mosque inside the US is alizing and they
actually got financing from the states
and the federal government different
grants so this is this is uh and this is
just a case that I I talked about many
other cases are happening another thing
I saw was a katari funded I'm not
talking now about uh IV League campuses
that are funded by by the qataris and
funding hate against the Jews and the
Israelis I'm talking now about uh I
think it was either the elementary or
high school system where they had an
Arabic or Arabic culture class and they
did not have the Israeli flag instead
they had Palestine
and this this Pro this thing this class
was uh in New York I think and it was
funded by the state of P terrorist state
of qar that's what I called it so what
do you how do you see this uh the spread
of islamism in the in the western world
and in americ General it's spreading
very rapidly and it's spreading without
anybody realizing what it is because one
of the first things that the people who
are spreading it did was make sure that
nobody would talk about it by
stigmatizing and demonizing anybody who
did talk about it as racist bigoted and
islamophobic and so all no you have ISL
you have Muslims talking about it yes
that's right so nobody is able to talk
about it nobody even is able to say that
there's any question about it or any
problem at all that if Kutter is pouring
money into American universities no
problem if the American universities
have the students agitating for Hamas
no problem because to say otherwise
would be islamophobic and racist so it
just goes on and it's going to get much
worse
okay
so at at the end of our show Robert
thanks again for coming you're you're a
great guest and thank you for accepting
my my uh my invitation I wna let's just
uh talk a bit about the
solutions how do you
see uh we said that uh is you know
personally I think that this Israeli
Palestine conflict would never end as
long as there's that's right religion
coming into it it's never going to end
even with the with the greatest
politicians of the world so how do you
see this conf conflict ending and uh do
you have any solutions for the
islamization of uh of America and the
Western World well you know it is a
religious conflict as we discussed at
the beginning and so as long as there
are believers in Muhammad and the Quran
and Allah there's going to be people
waging against Israel because they
believe that it's Islamic land and they
have to drive out the people who have
driven them out as the Quran says and so
even though the Israelis didn't really
drive them out that's what they're told
so they think they have the command from
Allah they have to fight so as long as
there are believers there will be Jihad
against Israel all that Israel can do is
stand strong one major thing it could do
was reject the idea of Palestinians
should never have accepted of them at
all the Palestinians are an invented
nationality you never hear about them in
history they never existed until the
1960s Jimmy Carter and anir Sadat forced
Bean the prime minister of Israel to
accept their existence at the Camp David
Accords in the 1970s the Israelis need
to repudiate them to emphasize that they
are Arabs who are no different
linguistically culturally ethnically
religiously from the Arabs in Syria
Lebanon and Jordan and that Syria
Lebanon and Jordan need to step up and
allow C them to be citizens there and
then if they had done that from the
beginning there never would have been a
problem yeah well what about the Islam
the spread of islamism Robert how can we
solve that states yes the big problem is
mass migration and there again you're
called a racist or an islamophobe or a
bigot if you say that it's not a good
idea but not a good idea because you
have people coming in who believe that
their culture and their way of life is
superior and so they will never
assimilate and accept the the the
culture and way of life of the people
who are already here so we can either
become an Islamic State eventually or we
have to stop the mass
migration if we stop the mass migration
then also we have to enforce the
existing laws here right now people are
too afraid they're once again here it's
always the same thing they're afraid of
being called racist so for example it's
against the law to have to be polygamous
but there are many Muslims who are
polygamous in the United States and the
law is not enforced because add to that
the W add to that the woke Yes W W ism
is making that worse right that's right
we have to recover the idea that there's
one set of laws that applies to everyone
and that would be a big help to start to
to to roll this back but instead these
parallel societies are being set up it's
only going to grow and there's going to
be Strife in the future as a result all
right well thank you Robert Robert
Spencer again thank you great to have
you good talking to you thank